[Musica]
il mondo del lavoro sta cambiando la
pandemia stravolto completamente il modo
in cui lavoriamo
la prima di addentrarmi nel modo in cui
la pandemia appunto sta impattando sulle
nostre vite sui nostri territori gli
chiederei la gente grazia di fare un
piccolo test insieme alzate la mano se
conoscete voi stessi lo sia anche una
persona che si è dovuta spostare per in
cerca di nuove opportunità di lavoro
studio al nord oppure all'estero anche
per un periodo limitato
provate ad alzare la mano
beh siamo in tanti
effettivamente grazie a mi troverete
essere
effettivamente la vostra storia come
quella dei vostri conoscenti e anche la
mia di dieci anni fa circa dopo avere
terminato il il mio lavoro
e il mio studio al liceo appunto mi sono
dovuto spostare per motivi di studio per
l'appunto all'università di bologna
città che mi ha accolto a braccia aperte
poi mi sono spostato in messico in
particolare a monterey poi anche in
spagna a barcellona
effettivamente le opportunità di scambio
di punto di spostarsi in un'altra città
del mondo dell'europa insomma che sia
sono fondamentali per la nostra crescita
culturale e professionale
ciò però non può tradursi evidentemente
nella costrizione a partire
la pandemia ha stravolto le nostre vite
le ha completamente rivoluzionate
ma ha soprattutto sconvolto anche il
mondo della loro
effettivamente a partire dall'inizio
della pandemia
oltre tra le 5 e le 7 milioni di persone
si sono trovate costrette a lavorare
caso sicuramente anche tanti e tante i
due si sono trovati in questa situazione
ma tra queste 57 milioni di persone 100
mila di queste l'hanno potuto fare hanno
potuto svolgere quelle loro attività
lavorative appunto dal dal sud per
aziende localizzate nel centro nord
secondo una collaborazione appunto
secondo il rapporto svimez 2020 che
abbiamo realizzato in collaborazione con
il centro di ricerca
beh effettivamente da marzo 2020 noi
come associazione abbiamo coniato questo
termine south working per descrivere
quello che si stava accadendo
lavoravamo su progetti a impatto locale
e abbiamo immaginato come appunto
proprio a marzo 2020 come cosa stava
accadendo attorno a noi devils of
working e il lavoro agile dal sud e
dalle aree emarginate italiane che
preveda però un impegno da parte delle
lavoratrici e dei lavoratori
a contribuire alla crescita dei
territori e delle comunità presso le
quali decidono di andare a vivere
infatti south working non è soltanto il
lavoro agile e soprattutto scriverò nel
dettaglio che cosa concretamente
significa in tutti i suoi aspetti
ma non è soltanto il lavoro agile quindi
smart work come abbiamo imparato a
conoscerlo sappiamo che quelle 57
milioni di persone in realtà hanno
svolto tale lavoro ma sa of working
significa anche la possibilità di
spendere il proprio denaro presso
commercio di prossimità del proprio
territorio
però sarebbe limitante pensare che
effettivamente south working è soltanto
questo evidentemente anche la
possibilità di contribuire alla crescita
come vi dicevo della propria comunità
non soltanto economicamente ma anche
condividendo con le persone le
amministrazioni comunali
con le società con le associazioni
territoriali le proprie competenze
addirittura quello che stiamo notando
attraverso i nostri studi e che chi sta
attorno che ha deciso anche di tornare
sta creando non e associazioni sta
creando nuove imprese e contribuisce in
maniera fattiva nella quotidianità alla
crescita del proprio territorio
come vi dicevo stiamo conducendo delle
ricerche che soltanto una parte delle
nostre attività e questo è il dramma
attraverso queste ricerche abbiamo
notato come tre cose sono assolutamente
fondamentali per poter fare southwark il
tutto ciò che non include questi tre
elementi non è salvo e sono tre
infrastrutture abilitanti
innanzitutto infrastruttura digitale
sembra scontato ma non meno non è così
effettivamente abbiamo avviato una
collaborazione con il principale player
italiano della fibra ottica per cercare
di portare nelle zone più remote
d'italia
ovviamente negli spazi dove si può
lavorare adesso ve ne parlerò la fibra è
fondamentale che ci sia che le persone
abbiano a disposizione una connessione a
internet rapida e sicura
ma non solo south working è anche e
soprattutto mobilità circolare in testa
però in un modo molto specifico perché
adesso le necessità sono cambiate la
pandemia ha rivoluzionato il modo in cui
lavoriamo
mobilità circolare nel senso non
soltanto di una mobilità sostenibile ma
anche della possibilità anzi necessità
da quello che ci dicono le migliaia di
interviste che stiamo conducendo di
spostarsi tra il luogo in cui il luogo
che si scelga il luogo dove da dove si
desidera lavorare e il duomo della
storia tradizionale di lavoro in un
movimento circolare
come potete immaginare motivo è
sicuramente penseranno ma come come come
possibile evidentemente molti territori
sono esclusi da questa d'acqua e
soprattutto i territori interni fornino
ovviamente anche un progetto di denuncia
e cerchiamo di portare all'attenzione
delle istituzioni le criticità
territoriali in termini di segua llanes
e poi infine forse l'aspetto che più
sento in maniera particolare cioè quello
delle infrastruttura sociale beh se è
vero che è necessario avere appunto
infrastruttura digitale che preveda una
connessione rapida e sicura ed è anche
la possibilità di spostarsi rapidamente
tra questi poli diversi dell'italia
dell'europa del mondo è anche vero che
per vivere su un territorio è necessario
che ci sia un infrastruttura sociale su
quel territorio fatta di luoghi di
servizi di base ovviamente ma di luoghi
e di persone che abitano quei luoghi
questi luoghi mi piace chiamarli presidi
comunità
i luoghi sono i presidi comunità sono
spazi di aggregazione sociale dai quali
si può effettivamente lavorare in
maniera agile collaborando con il
territorio che sulle quali questi sui
quali vestiti insistono
i presidi comunità sono quindi sparsi di
coworking biblioteche musei con spazi
sottoutilizzati che abbiamo
rifunzionalizzato sono luoghi quindi di
collaborazione innovazione di socialità
combattiamo assolutamente quell'effetto
grotta e quella totale remotizzazione
del lavoro svolto soprattutto da casa
che tanto ci ha danneggiato che ci ha in
parte anche traumatizzato
beh effettivamente come vi dicevo il
lavoro il lavoro agile e quello del
south working è un lavoro fatto di
relazioni di socialità
ma ovviamente questa socialità si basa
sulla creazione di reti relazionali
quello che stiamo cercando di fare ogni
giorno attraverso l'associazione reti
fatte appunto di persone comuni di
persone operatori delle associazioni
delle cooperative
delle amministrazioni locali delle
imprese e delle istituzioni religiose
culturali un mondo assolutamente
variegato ma tutti sposano un principio
fondamentale
cooperare e collaborare e co progettare
servizi e attività in maniera
sostenibile per il proprio
sicuramente è uno strumento che sono
strumenti e processi che abbiamo
adottato proprio per combattere lo
spopolamento
evidentemente questo è su questo che
questa fotografia ha sorpreso molte
istituzioni e rappresentanti delle
istituzioni che non erano
particolarmente
convinti dell'idea
inizialmente beh abbiamo mappato in
maniera partecipata 230 spazi dalle
guarda ai quali si può lavorare in
maniera agile oggi non domani
effettivamente sono tanti ma non sono
mai abbastanza perché evidentemente ci
sono delle diseguaglianze che riguardi
territoriali che sono assolutamente
drammatica e da colmare alcuni esempi
però sono particolarmente rilevanti
soltanto per citare alcuni esempi in
sicilia
partendo in alto a sinistra licata nella
provincia di agrigento un presidio di
particolare successo in uno spazio
privato già esistente che si è associata
la nostra rete così continuando verso
destra castelbuono e poi petralia
sottana isnello le attività sono tante
ma soprattutto mi preme segnalare come
in questi luoghi troverete se ne andate
a visitare e vi invito a farlo
ovviamente basta andare poi sulla mappa
appunto sul sito per verificare come
come dire come questi luoghi siano tanti
e particolarmente
interessanti lì mi preme segnalare come
questi luoghi sono fatti di persone
intraprendenti che si mettono in gioco
quotidianamente per la crescita del
proprio territorio ma andando
recandovi in questi luoghi non troverete
soltanto i gestori evidentemente di
questi spazi ma anche coloro che sono
tornati al sud che sono tornati nelle
aree interne italiane e che stanno
impiegando proprio il loro tempo non
soltanto per lavorare come vi dicevo per
le sedi che evidentemente si trovano
altrove genere mentre al nord all'estero
ma trovate persone che si impegnano per
il proprio territorio io ho portato
alcune senti che ritengono
particolarmente interessanti come quello
di antonio che l'ingegnere gestionale
di palermo che si è dovuto spostare per
motivi di studio prima a torino poi per
motivi di lavoro a milano consulente in
ambito data analytics che adesso a
partire da pandemia si è trasferito a
palermo tornato nella sua città di
origine non immaginiamo assolutamente di
poter fare poter svolgere il suo lavoro
dalla sua città natale questo ci ha
detto durante una delle nostre
interviste o ancora per esempio claudia
una ragazza pugliese che lavora falsa of
working tra e spostandosi tra
manfredonia e roma claudiana lavora per
un operatore delle infrastrutture di
rete non pensava anche lei di poter
tornare con questa frequenza appunto a
manfredonia ma invece sta sperimentando
la possibilità di recuperare e di
rinsaldare i rapporti col proprio
territorio
un aspetto che particolarmente emotivo
direi è quello che ci ha confidato
claudia proprio del recupero delle
sensazioni e delle atmosfere del proprio
territorio con i odori il calore il mare
evidentemente che non sono affatto
aspetti da sottovalutare dato che è
l'ambiente che ci circonda ci rende poi
quelli che siamo
inoltre anche giuseppe ingegnere
informatico calabrese che prima lavorava
per lo più a milano adesso giuseppe ha
scelto di trasferirsi di ritornare e
spostarsi tra cosenza e torre mezzo di
falconara albanese
l'aria interna
lavora perfettamente i smart working fa
le sue riunioni evidentemente anche in
presenza
così quando poi quando d'accordo con la
sua azienda a milano ma giuseppe ci ha
detto chiaramente che la produttività
non è diminuita e aumentata
questa nuova opportunità del fab four
kings per lui gli ha permesso di anche
per il mio punto di vista dare
nuovamente legami con la propria
famiglia ma non soltanto di riscoprire
relazioni ormai perse con amici
conoscenti di avviare nuovi progetti sul
territorio come sta facendo
brillantemente è per lui un aspetto che
mi ha particolarmente colpito che
condivido pienamente è quella
l'aspetto fondamentale per cui ci sono
tanti professionisti uomini e donne che
sono si trovano al sud che per
l'impossibilità per motivi personali o
professionali di spostarsi rimangono
fuori da un mercato del lavoro che ormai
è assolutamente globale
inoltre giuseppe ha fatto un appunto che
anche questo ritengo molto interessante
cioè la possibilità per questi
lavoratori e lavoratrici di
ritornare non soltanto nelle grandi
città del sud dove desiderano lavorare
ma soprattutto di ripopolare i borghi
italiani che è un capitale immenso perso
purtroppo per l'occhio e infine vi
racconto l'ultima storia molto
brevemente a quella di marte giulia
milanese luna romana l'altra scelgono di
venire a palermo prima dell'inizio della
pandemia rimangono stregate
completamente da dalla nostra città io
sono originario di palermo
come vi dicevo
e raccontano attraverso il loro profilo
instagram non soltanto palermo ma tutti
i luoghi dove poi si recano
probabilmente motivo e anche le avranno
viste perché veramente iniziato il
fenomeno social particolarmente
importante su su instagram
bene mi sembra evidente che il modo in
cui stiamo ragionando oggi generale va
soltanto con soft walking parlo del
dibattito che
necessaria e fondamentale che si deve
creare in questo momento in italia e nel
resto del mondo ci condizionerà
significativamente su come lavoreremo
tra 5 10 anni
in particolare credo che saranno proprio
gli interventi sulle infrastrutture
digitali di mobilità e sociali quelle di
cui vi ho parlato oggi
a modificare il modo in cui lavoreremo
e quindi non potendo predire il futuro
mi auguro evidentemente che il futuro
possa essere segnato da un lavoro
dignitoso e sicuro
sa che molte persone più persone
possibili possano effettivamente
scegliere dove lavorare e che si
adottino dei modelli di organizzazione
del territorio delle imprese che siano
sostenibili
però il cambiamento non avviene da
storia il cambiamento va portato con
attenzione mandandoli fuori comunque
conquistandolo
grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]